hey what's up folks i'm international
master acoustic kabutsuki
and today i'll be doing the recap video
for the 2020 us women's championship
so the tournament was won by grandmaster
irina crush with eight and a half out of
11.
she ended up doing really well in the
final half of the tournament and playing
some really really good chess
and this is actually her eighth national
title victory so
a huge huge score there for irena it's
actually the first title she's won
in several years as the field has only
gotten stronger and stronger in recent
events and the tournament has just
gotten tougher
and tougher but she managed to pull it
off uh this time and i'll be presenting
some of her
key wins first she ends up winning her
last
three games of the event this was an 11
round
uh round robin tournament uh rapid event
25 plus five was the time control
and this round nine game against uh
women's gm taraba rahamian
was really well played i think this was
one of the best games in the tournament
so black's last move in this position
was this move knight to d5 i believe
queen b6 was the the theory here and and
black is supposed to be okay in this
line
but this move knight d5 is definitely a
mistake and irena ends up
punishing it really accurately starting
with the move knight g5
threatening main and one on h7 and
forcing black to
defend against this with some kind of
weakening move either f5 or g6
black plays g6 white takes on d5 queen
takes d5
and now just castles taking advantage of
the pin on the d-file and
the fact that black of course cannot
take on e3
so black here plays bishop e7 hits the
knight on g5
white gains a tempo with bishop c4 queen
a5
and now h4 kind of a multi-purpose move
not just defending the knight on g5
but also using the pawn in the attack as
one day white can definitely
consider playing h5 here and uh trying
to
take on g6 uh so black here takes on e3
this is the one moment where i think
arena definitely could have improved on
her play
as they pointed out in the broadcast um
f takes e3 here
would have been i think a much stronger
choice than the move playing in the game
bishop takes e3
just opening up the f-file and including
the rook into the attack and
yeah the engines just go crazy here for
white and say that black
is already just not defending this
position but after bishop takes e3 white
kept a big advantage here
and uh ends up um playing really really
well just to
uh convert on her initiative queen e2 h6
and uh here white plays really strong
counter attacking move rook to d5 queen
went back to c7 rook c1 gaining another
tempo
knight to c6 and now really really
fantastic sacrifice
rook takes f5 so main idea here as irena
explained
after the game is that on g takes f5 her
plan
i believe was to go queen h5 and uh
threatening queen
g6 check with just a very very powerful
attack
and if black goes hg here then her plan
was already
just to recapture with the h pawn now
threatening the move
g6 where black can't take because of
this pin on the diagonal
and this g6 move would be just leading
uh to a really powerful
remaining attack for for white here uh
with queen h7 uh
mate on the agenda now we end up getting
this position
actually by transposition oddly enough
in the game after rick takes f5
black decided to take on g5 first uh and
irena just very calmly recaptures here
hg
with the idea that after g takes f5
black finally accepting the rook
now white plays queen h5 and we have the
same exact position
as before white is down a full rook but
the attack is just too strong
and black is completely busted here todd
have tried queen e5 just getting the
queen back to
uh defense g6 queen g7 uh now white has
a bunch of wins here the one they
pointed out on on the show was uh
really really stunning and it would have
been a remarkable way to finish the game
rick takes c6 b takes c6 removing the
defender of the d4 square so that white
could play bishop to d4
and illustrating another tactical motive
here uh of deflection trying to
get this queen away from the h7 square
so that white can give meat
and yeah just a total uh demonstration
of the power of the two bishops here
with one bishop uh helping the attack
the other bishop pinning the f pawn and
not allowing black to play f6
and yeah this would have been a
fantastic way to end the game
but irena's way was was no less
convincing she went for
somewhat simpler bishop to h6 black play
queen f6
she pulls the bishop back to d2 uh
reinstating the threat of queen h7
black has to go queen to g7 as in all of
these lines if the queen tries to take
on g6
of course white would just recapture and
black would not be able to take this one
so black played queen g7 and then after
bishop c3
it was all over well i can try to block
with pieces on the diagonal but of
course this queen always has to stay
tied down to the h7 square and after
bishop takes f6 black would not be able
to recapture without getting mated
and thus had to resign so with this win
irena actually overtook
the lead that was previously being held
by carissa yep the
recent winner of the 2020 uh us girls
junior championship
up until this point round nine chris had
actually been leading the tournament
she had overtaken irina at some point
and in this critical round chris
actually lost her game to ashrita
eswaran
allowing arena to win this game and
leapfrog her in
the standings so that means going into
the final day
karissa yep was a half point behind
arena and i believe
i am dorsa derek shawnee was also just a
half point behind irena
going into the final two rounds so it
was a really really exciting
final day as um both of these players
carissa and dorsa were
having good tournaments and very hungry
to catch up to irina and
basically irena had to win out her games
in order to actually clinch
the title she had to win her final two
games and she ended up doing it
in really nice style her first round
of the uh final day the penultimate
round was against sabina
boyzar here and um sabine in this
position
uh goes for a pretty sharp sacrifice
with
knight takes g5 the point being after
uh hg rook takes h8 bishop takes h8
queen h5
white has unleashed this kind of pretty
uh unpleasant double attack against the
bishop on h8
so white is threatening to win her piece
back but is also threatening to take
this pawn on f7
and start attacking black's king so
not an easy position to defend in fact
irina here
makes a mistake and gives her opponent a
chance this move bishop to f6
this one ends up going unpunished a
stronger move was the
just immediate king move king to d7
a really tough move to play but it's
kind of prophylactic defending the
bishop
and also getting out of check in advance
and the point here we can see compared
to the game is that the king is just
immediately running to c7 so if white
castles here black will play king to c7
and the king is actually reasonably safe
and white won't have enough compensation
for the piece black would be better
instead after bishop f6
sabine ends up just taking the spawn and
we essentially just get the same kind of
position and black ends up
doing well here but she did have a
chance with this move
castles i thought this was really
interesting had she found this one
actually irena would have been
in big trouble as now that the rook is
on the d file of course the king can't
think of stepping on d7 the knight would
move with a devastating
discovered attack and in the meantime
the king is kind of
caught on e8 black can play the move e6
to at least defend the f7 pawn
but then white would follow up with f4
this is of course
uh stockfish all the way
that i use for this analysis but
apparently this would have been a very
very
strong attack the idea here being that
white wants to push e5 and then bring
the knight to e4 and one day
visit the d6 square or the f6 square
basically white would have had a pretty
uh
difficult attack for for black to deal
with here instead after queen takes f7
king d7
black's king looks precarious but is
actually safe
castles king to c7 here white plays the
move knight to b3
unleashing a pretty uh again unpleasant
double attack again
against the queen on d8 pawn on c5
and here arena finds a very accurate
very strong defensive move
uh knight to e5 counter attacking the
queen on f7 hitting the bishop
on c4 if white takes the queen on d8
black will
take on f7 and since this rook is still
hanging white doesn't have time to uh
take the knight here
and black would just have an extra piece
in the end game and be winning
so instead black had to go back with
queen to h5
but now queen h8 black wins another
tempo because white just
cannot trade queens in this position has
to go back and
black finally uses that key tempo to
just defend the c5 pawn
really kill the knight on b3 and now
white is essentially
run out of compensation bishop d5 rook
to b8 was played
black soon played e6 just got all our
pieces out and uh the game was
uh it went on for a bit of time but i
think
irina had really good control over this
game and and the result was
was never in doubt so in order to keep
up
uh carissa and dorsa had to win their
games dorsa was winning but ended up
being held to a draw so she uh dropped
back a little bit behind
but karissa had a really crazy game
against uh anna
zatonski um anna was not doing well in
this event so she's usually one of the
contenders for the title but
but this year yeah she just didn't
perform well in the online format
and even though chris was actually worse
and pretty much losing the whole game
she kept fighting and eventually reaches
this position where
she's down in exchange but has already
taken something on h4
and is now kind of uh threatening to
open up white's king and then
create some some counter play um and
this is where the moment where
white uh goes wrong there were a couple
ways for white to
essentially win the game i think this
move e5 was strong
as well as throwing in queen b8 check
first to cover g3
and then maybe playing e5 um but here
instead
white ends up going for rook ca check
and taking the pawn on f7
but the issue is that now black takes on
g3 and actually starts creating some
some real counter play threatening to
just take on f2
and open up white's king and in the
meantime white's counter play with
anything like rick to c7
is kind of slow because everything is
coming with check
so white takes back the pawn uh chris
starts giving checks
takes his pawn gives some more checks
and at this point i think the
commentators were expecting black
to uh take a draw here by perpetual
because she was basically losing the
whole game
but the tournament standings kind of
dictate that uh
carissa needed to play four win here
because she's already half point behind
irina
and i'm not sure if she was keeping an
eye on irina's game or not but
if she was she would know that irena is
is winning at this point
um so she was probably thinking that she
needs to play for a win
uh at all costs and and here she does it
she just
comes up with this very strong move
knight to g4
i think objectively white uh is not
losing here but it's a really tough
uh position and the point is that this
queen g8 check that she now allows is
just
one check the king will come up to h6
white doesn't have any real counter play
and in the meantime black is earning a
bunch of meeting ideas with queen f2
queen h2
now i believe the only move here for
white to not lose the game on the spot
was just move bishop to c4 very very
tough move to find
especially when you're in heavy time
trouble as both players were
the time scramble here was really crazy
there was a lot of mistakes
made by by both players um white played
bishop g2
of course understandable with so little
time on your clock
you know no one is going to play uh like
an engine in this situation
um but it was really interesting what
happened black played queen to e3 check
king to h1 and uh now the stone cold can
uh killing move here was queen takes g3
threatening made on h2
and in case of queen to g1 black has
queen h4 check and is going to be mating
in a couple moves here
so this was the killer but when you're
low on time you know you have seconds on
your clock you're just relying on this
increment
you it's really hard to play a move that
isn't a check
when you have checks in the position so
of course krista plays queen h6 check
um with queen h2 on the agenda white
goes king g1 so
white plays bishop to h3 and now knight
e3 a very difficult move to deal with
as white's queen is needs to protect the
bishop but
the knight hits the queen covers the g2
square and all of a sudden
white is losing um the bishop on on h3
it seems
so ana panicked here she played this
move queen f3 looks natural but
after queen takes h3 king to g1 uh black
could have already taken the rook here
she misses that she goes knight g4
instead but at this point black is
already completely winning here with two
pieces for the rook
and the raging attack continuing with
bishop d4 check queen h2
and just so many threats uh in the
position
um instead had anna had a little bit
more time
she might have found basically a really
really nice defensive resource here
actually
after any one of these moves queen g1
queen f2 or queen
e2 white could then meet queen takes h3
check
with queen h2 uh blocking and
pinning black's own queen meaning that
after any one of these moves when the
queen comes to h2
this would actually indirectly defend
the work on c8 as black's
queen is of course pinned to the king so
black would be forced to trade queens
here
and then white would be uh totally fine
i mean all three results still
uh 100 possible in in uh
difficult you know nervous time scramble
but uh objectively white would be
uh quite safe so kind of unlucky for
anna that she doesn't find this she ends
up putting the queen on f3
and uh loses the game but that means
that karissa stays within a half point
of irena
going into the final round now the final
round of course was pretty
uh nerve-wracking we had carissa yep
playing against uh talia cervantes
and irena crush playing against emily
nguyen um
so both of the top seeds kind of uh
playing down
with white and needing to win their
games
i think carissa was the first one to end
up winning her game and it was a pretty
nice and interesting uh open sicilian i
want to start from this moment because i
think this is where carissa really
takes over it's a very uh complicated
position i mean black is the two bishops
but obviously
a really vulnerable king and and here
white just starts playing against this
king starting with the move e5
um the immediate point of this move is
that white is actually just opening up
the e4 square for the knight this is a
pretty typical
idea these kinds of positions to open up
the e4 square then the knight would be
hitting the queen but also
hitting the g5 square and d6 and
really causing a lot of problems so
black plays d5 but now
closes up the center we get more of a
french-like structure and this bishop on
c8 immediately becomes a lot less happy
white goes queen to g2 g6 rook h1 really
calm but really strong play by chrissa
here
just taking over the h file preparing to
bring her second rook to h1
and uh playing against black's king
although in this case if rook takes h1
since
knight on d4 is hanging white would
probably play queen takes h1
and try to get her queen in on the h
file
uh here black play bishop d7 white uh
took on h4 bishop takes h4
queen takes g4 uh bishop f2 and now
again just simple move knight f3
and white is just re-maneuvering all of
her pieces to the king side there's a
ton of weaknesses there
and any kind of counter play on the
queen side here for black is
just not in time white's attack is a lot
stronger
uh talia tries to defend here but
white's piece is simply
uh overwhelm and yeah chris have played
this part of the game
really really uh powerfully rook h1 just
bringing the rook back i think rook h2
might have been a little bit stronger
but
rook h1 is totally fine bishop c6 queen
h3 and
now black just doesn't have a great
defense to uh white's queen
coming in uh king f8 knight takes e6
and yeah this is of course just
completely over queen hha check ends the
game on the spot
she decided to take queen c8 and black
resign because now
losing the bishop on on c6 and
everything with check and
yeah game just completely over so with
carissa
winning this game she was temporarily
ahead of arena in the standings by a
half point
and in order to clinch the title irena
would need to
win her game against emily nguyen
a draw would then lead to some kind of
blitz or a rapid
playoff and irena ends up playing a
really
nice game here this comes from an
exchange slav where
white gave up her light square bishop on
c6 in order to leave black with this
weak c
pawn and put some pressure on this pawn
but at the same time irena also started
advancing on the king side here and ends
up causing uh some grief to to black's
king
now at this point uh black's position is
already pretty difficult
c6 pawn is hanging white is also
preparing to play
a move like rook h1 much like in chris's
game and start taking over the h file
um and here emily decides to go for this
tactic
with knight takes g4 which i think is
very understandable given that her
position
uh is quite difficult so the point of
this one is that white cannot take the
bishop on e7 as this would run into
knight takes e3 check forking the king
and queen
instead white goes f takes g4 black
plays bishop takes g5 and
wins a pawn but now black's king is has
been opened up and irene
irene immediately takes advantage rook
gf1 check king to e7 and queen to g6
just coming in
uh she played this part of the game
really really well bishop f6
g5 and uh now emily tries to at least
make a tricky plays rook to g8
white can't take on f6 as after gf the
rook
will uh pin the queen and the king um
but
rook h1 very calm trying to eliminate
black's counter play
now the threat is to take on h8
distracts one of black's rooks away from
the g
file trade off a rook and then white
would be able of course to
take on f6 black plays queen b5
very annoying move trying to come in
with queen to e2
but now again very cool common collected
king f3
not just covering the square with the
king but also stepping off of the g
file and reinstating the threat of
taking on f6
black's hook on h1 here rook takes h1
rook f8
another tricky move once again white
can't take as she'll lose her queen
after rook takes f6
and irena finds i think the absolute
only winning move here king to g3
just stepping off of the f-file not
allowing queenie to with check
and once again threatening to take the
uh the bishop on f6
well black tried i think the best
possible try just goes queen e2 anyway
and uh hits this one on e3 um irena
takes the bishop on f6 with check
and now rick takes f6 was played g takes
f6 here might have been a slightly uh
more annoying move for white to deal
with i think this kind of keeps more
chances for black in the position
but white would be winning uh if she
continues accurately here of course with
something like rook h7
and then queen to g4 just giving up the
e3 pawn
but start to run up with the king and
uh main point here is that queen f2
check is met with queen to g3
and if y can just trade queens here then
it's gonna be
pretty much all over and i can try to
come to c5 and we can try to set up
meet with rick to d7 so
white would have had to really be
precise here to win
uh against this line black instead plays
rook takes f6
uh then white takes on g7 here rook f7
queen g5 check king to d7 and
now white is winning but of course it's
still very very tricky and
you know the pressure of the tournament
and the clock i'm sure is building up
and black has a lot of very annoying uh
checks uh
threatened with queen f2 queen f3 rook
f3 here so but irina was
quite precise she finds knight c5 check
and it turns out that
black's king here is just getting mated
whenever the king goes to the back rank
then white gets to include the rook on
the h file
and after king 2 c7 here queen e5 check
was played
and king to b6 queen to b8
that was the end of the championship as
only move rick b7
why would play queen takes b7 and it
would be made on
the board so fantastic finish by irina
she really had to keep her cool there
restricting her opponent's counter play
until the very last second
being very very accurate with very very
little time on her on her clock
but she ends up just uh barely winning
the event with eight and a half
out of 11. krista finished with eight
out of 11 and another player who did
really well i want to give a shout out
to is is dorsa derek shani
who finished with seven and a half out
of 11 uh clear third place
uh dorsa in particular surprised a lot
of people because she was the 12th
seed in the event so i had to come in as
a tall seed and end up finishing
in third place uh yeah she had like uh i
think
remarkable event a ton of nice wins from
dorsa i
want to highlight one from one of the
earlier rounds uh this was against uh
ana zatonski here
and i want to back up a little bit in
this game um
here in a winner where uh dorsa started
with a really interesting
uh and pretty thematic plan in this
position with a4
just launching the a pawn up the board
trying to get to a5
opening some lines on the queen side and
also opening up the a3 square for the
dark squared bishop
uh black hair played knight to b8 and
tries to get the knight to c6
but white is able to at least open the a
file uh in castle here
here black plays knight to a5 trying to
get to the c4 square
uh and dorsa unleashes a really strong
really instructive exchange sacrifice
rick takes a five and it's kind of a
slow burn but after
b takes a5 bishop a3 the compensation
becomes pretty clear white's dark
squared bishop is
uh an absolute powerhouse in this
position the rook is coming to
b1 and at a certain point white is going
to play c4
and just crack open the position so king
b7 was tried
knight f4 just improving the knight
knight h6 c4
and uh very nice move just putting
maximum pressure on black's center if d
takes c4 here
as displayed in the game white goes
brook to b1 check
and now the problem is that if king goes
to the corner of course queen f3
is a huge problem black cannot block
queen d5 because of the knight
and the king goes back to somewhere like
c8 then just queen f3 anyway
and this queen is coming in uh and the
white's attack is basically unstoppable
uh so black was forced to play king to
a6 here
now with the king basically cut off and
almost getting mated here
dorsa finds a really nice move knight to
d3
basically threatening knight c5 not just
forking the king and queen but just
mating the king on the spot
and of course this comes with the clever
point that on c takes d3
white can recapture with the queen in
its mate next move
black played rook to c8 here knight to
c5 black is forced to give back the
exchange
bishop takes c5 and the incredible thing
about this game actually is that i
looked it up in the database and this
was actually all been played
before in a game by a grandmaster
malacatian good friend of mine shout out
to malek
um 15 years ago in a game in uh in santa
monica
california so pretty incredible this has
actually all been played before and
of course white white is completely uh
winning here as black's king on a6 just
can't possibly survive uh in this game
black plays rook c8 this was the first
new move of the game in the previous
game black tried f4
and of course just ended up getting made
it anyway um
but after rick c8 white finished things
off here with queen c3
and queen to b2 just lining the queen
and rook uh
up on the b file and threatening uh
checkmate on b7
rook c7 was played bishop d6 white's
attack here just kind of flows
uh very naturally here um d5
nice breakthrough there are many ways
for white to win in this position but
this one is certainly really satisfying
as the e pawn starts
chasing black's rook rook takes d6 of
course not possible because of queen to
b7
uh black played c3 here kind of last
ditch attempt queen to b8
and uh here black resigned as uh there's
just too many threats in the position
and
yeah no defense so really nice game by
my dorson congrats to her on
her uh incredible third place finish so
up next is the us championship which
starts on october 26th
that's going to be a really really
exciting and high level event i'm very
much looking forward to
covering that one and i'll be back here
on youtube for you guys with another
recap video at the end of that event
so until then take care